hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for June 1st 2020 ow
the summer's here and I just feel like
if a bunch of people can get together
and throw bricks through the windows of
a target I can go to the beach okay
because if I can't do that isn't that
like a double standard Oh big shout-out
to anybody who actually could sit there
and watch the news over the last week
and continue to watch the news and do
all of that I don't know why you would
do that to yourself it's gonna give you
a horrible idea of humanity and what
people are like I would venture to say
that 99.9% of the population is not
writing is not pulling people over and
then you know beating them up murdering
them or whatever okay but if you want to
sit there and watch the news and get all
[ __ ] bummed out about that [ __ ] I
mean that is that is your prerogative
and I salute you for wanting to be that
informed however I I do understand that
there's always going to be
mouth-breathers and there's always gonna
be you know misdirected anger there's
gonna be a bunch of stuff but you got to
keep your eye on the ball on this thing
okay you know I just think that there
needs to be really reality is is if we
ever want to solve this everyone would
have to get involved and everyone would
have to give a [ __ ] and I think it would
go beyond you know just tweeting black
lives matter and there I did my part
like you'd really have to like this
there's no reason to just be still doing
this to each other there's no [ __ ]
reason for there just as there's no
reason for it and I you know I don't
know I just don't understand how
somebody can be face down with handcuffs
even though
it appears there was some sort of
altercation in the back of the cruiser
there was some sort of resisting arrest
you know you shouldn't do that they
already got you you are handcuffed or
whatever but like at some point when
you're faced out and you know handcuffs
saying I can't breathe I just don't
understand and I'm ignorant of the whole
process I don't understand why you can't
just ease up your knee maybe move your
knee off of the neck you could still be
I mean I don't know what sort of human
being with their arms behind their back
can do you know was he worried that the
guy was gonna start doing the worm and
[ __ ] flip him off and then I don't
know break his handcuffs I don't know
what deal was but when somebody says
they can't breathe and the unprecedent
amount of leaders that are just saying
insightful things is just unbelievable
like if you can say I can't breathe that
means you can breathe and it's just like
buddy if that was your daughter or your
son or you would you really have that
same perspective you know what I mean
there's different levels of not being
able to breathe it's not getting a full
breath okay that would be like if a
[ __ ] Python grabbed you and started
to squeeze you and you're like dude help
me out help me up breathe I mean it's so
and even though that dude was from
Mississippi I'm not judging everybody
down there in Mississippi I'm sure
there's plenty of people that can kind
of see this thing so hopefully you know
I think the curfews are a great thing
that'll stop the mouth-breathing morons
from attacking small businesses for
whatever [ __ ] reason you know I would
think if there was some sort of like
through line to the outrage you would go
after major corporations rather than
mom-and-pop stores I don't know why
people would do that but anyway and then
the white people also looting going down
they're like it's Spring Break like hey
let's [ __ ] act like we're oppressed
see what this feels like
[Laughter]
I don't understand that either and it's
all just so the whole thing is [ __ ]
weird but it's the still the focus is
that there and it was so great to see so
many police officers saying that that
that situation Minneapolis was not
handled correctly that is unprecedented
you know there's always been everybody
just the cops always just stayed with
each other and it's timed like to
correct that problem and I think it's
time to hear from both sides because
also being a cop every night you could
get killed and you're going up to a
vehicle you have no [ __ ] idea what
the person is gonna do you can't see
their [ __ ] hands you don't know
what's going on and who wants to die
nobody I mean it's a it's an incredibly
difficult job I would think so I think
that needs to be some empathy you need
to listen and all of these people you
know who are just Fanning the flames I
just don't understand unless you enjoy
it you just [ __ ] have hate in your
heart or something I don't understand
what this is and you know I don't know I
don't know but I would not judge people
by these idiots at night doing what
they're doing I understand some of the
rage and that type of stuff but I just
go into somebody's mom-and-pop store and
just [ __ ] burning it down and taking
all their [ __ ] like I don't know that
just seems like that's just sort of a
that's not a smart move
all right there I said it okay as I said
my little [ __ ] piece what do I any
know what I wanna do now I'm gonna get
back to my [ __ ] job which is trying
to make people laugh during all of this
[ __ ] chaos when you're running down
the street with the microwave you know
as much as you shouldn't do that you
know you're technically also working on
your Beachbody all right and goddamn it
the [ __ ] beaches are open the
restaurants are open I actually ate at a
restaurant last night I was taking my
wife for a drive and there was this
burger place we always wanted to go to
so we called up ordered went to pick up
and went in and there was people sitting
like
every three booths away from each other
and I was like you know it's a burger
its fries a root beer it's gonna be
messy to eat in the car I said can we go
over there to sit there and they're like
yeah so we did that I don't know if that
was the right thing and the wrong thing
to do but I feel pretty good today can
tell you that and I've just been driving
around Los Angeles really learning about
the city on these drives like just kind
of getting the something you usually
can't do in LA which is cruise around
because there's always there's so much
traffic out here and I've learned about
[ __ ] bike paths and and and the
street and Van Nuys where people still I
guess Wednesday nights whatever they
still cruise up and down the where they
shot like American Graffiti had no idea
about that
restaurants architecture all these
different little subsets of City out
cities outside LA beautiful views and
[Music]
you know just being in the entertainment
business for some reason it's always
been all about getting into like Beverly
Hills the Pacific Palisades like
everybody wants that same view you know
unobstructed downtown LA all the way out
to the ocean that's that's the but there
are so many more views to have in this
city that are just as breathtaking for
like a third of the price and with
people probably who aren't in the
entertainment business so be cool to
live out there and just [ __ ] get away
from it and [ __ ] so I've really enjoyed
doing that in LA you know gets a really
bad rap as far as like plastic people
and [ __ ] smog and all this [ __ ] it
has some of the most beautiful houses in
architecture of any city I've ever been
in and the views if you can just get
yourself a little ways up in a hill and
look over a couple houses it looks like
Christmas every night it's [ __ ]
amazing so I don't know what happened I
somehow really over the years have I
love this city the way I love like East
Coast cities now and all the food and
that type of stuff and
really missin you know food trucks and
all that type of [ __ ] but it seems like
we're starting to turn the corner on all
of this stuff so that's a good thing and
I think with all of the stuff that's
going on all the other stuff the George
Floyd stuff I think the best way to go
about it you should rather than tweet
tweeting [ __ ] I think you literally have
to like do with what what feminists did
they knew if we just [ __ ] no one's
gonna give a [ __ ] we have to go after
the money so they would go after the
advertisers if there was somebody that
they wanted to you know silence or make
apologize or whatever for better or
worse sometimes they will write
sometimes they abused their power but it
seems like that's the way to go that you
would talk to politicians and people
like that but I don't know I actually
have a positive feeling about this I
feel like this is going to be a tipping
point the fact that you saw police
officers walking with protesters and and
police officers speaking out against it
saying that's not good police work you
shouldn't do it that way I think is a
major major step that I have not seen in
the past so actually as ugly as all of
this is and depressing I think it's it's
gonna be it's got to be a positive thing
today you got a look at it now let's get
let's get to something not positive
let's talk about the presidential
election coming up
Biden verse Trump or as I like to call
it the dud versus the dope Democrats are
you trying to lose the election once
again boxing out Bernie Sanders is in
100% full effect I mean that is the
fight you want to see this is like when
you want to see Pacquiao Mayweather
[ __ ] Mayweather keeps fighting on
all these other [ __ ] guys you know
instead I don't understand it like
bernie is the Democrat version of Trump
he is a rebel he is outside the lines
all right you got to fight fire with
fire you get they're gonna bring another
company man in like they did with
Hillary
it's a [ __ ] mistake
but Jesus Christ I you know I try to
stay out of the politics [ __ ] I really
do like Mike Pence doesn't bug me it
[ __ ] you know what watching a guy
fanning the [ __ ] flames in talking
about shooting American citizens with
the National Guard like that guy is just
like he does not he can't be that dumb
he just doesn't he just they you turn on
a microphone he's just gonna start
talking like if this guy was in the
[ __ ] mob like he would he I don't
think he wouldn't even get whacked cuz
he wouldn't even ascend to any sort of
level you know Donnie the mouth
[Music]
[Laughter]
dony dumb dumb I don't know what the
[ __ ] they would call him but there's no
[ __ ] way they would put that guy in
charge of anything at some point they
would I didn't they would just stop
returning his calls anyway and and then
like I don't understand Joe Biden Joe
Biden is like you know I don't know
listen to that guy [ __ ] give a speech
is like I feel like I'm a community
service you know I would rather go pick
up litter on the side of the highway
I would actually enjoy that knowing that
I was making the city cleaner not the
earth by the way you make the city
cleaner that whole [ __ ] [ __ ] put
litter in its place where the animals
live where we can't see it it still
[ __ ] exists however you know I would
enjoy doing that more so than listen to
that guy give a [ __ ] speech Jesus
Christ I'm gonna sneeze in a bad way
Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] I ate at a
restaurant last night I have it anyway
yeah I'm trying to avoid all this [ __ ]
that I watched I watched our real sports
with Bryant Gumbel about you know the
covetous and how they they weren't
giving them out to people who were
doctors and nurses and stuff like this
and this poor woman got exposed to it
and she exposed her sister to her and
her sister died it's one of the worst
[ __ ] things I've ever seen
I just here's a question I have for you
guys why when there's a decision on the
table choosing more money or choosing
the right thing why is it never the same
it's always a fork in the road why is
more money always worse morally you know
I don't know I've been fascinated with
the whole human [ __ ] behavior and
looking at it knowing that I'm also
human so I'm not judging people but and
I've been guilty of this I really think
that human beings at the end of the day
one of our major flaws is we would
rather win than be right you know I find
myself so many times arguing with my
wife about [ __ ] you know when she
gives me you know some sort of feminist
rhetoric and I'll actually no she's
right and just because she's saying it
about guys and I'm a guy I just will
[ __ ] argue it and it takes me like
two or three days to be that guy you
know what you will write you wanna
[ __ ] you just say that all right the
same way you can't you can't admit that
you're a little messy you know oh my
wife loves a corner of a room whoa she
will [ __ ] throw some [ __ ] in the
corner of a room just a bunch of FUD
Rives me up the [ __ ] wall not a big
fan of the clutter that's a good name
for a band the clutter you know then if
people [ __ ] on your album well I mean
you heard the name of the band why the
[ __ ] would you listen to it so anyway I
went on a did something real dangerous
yesterday I actually went on a little
bike ride here in LA I just figured it
was Sunday morning I could get away with
it and I forgot my mask I was such a
[ __ ] yesterday I forgot my mass and I
already like had gone down a few hills
I'm like I'm not going all the way back
so I just sort of rode away from people
and [ __ ] like that but like I still
don't like riding out in the street you
know God knows there's no bike lanes out
here you know just cuz they paint a
bicycle in the middle of the street you
know and just the way some people ride
bicycles that [ __ ]
we were riding down the street and you
and somebody else are riding and you
ride next to the person blocking the
whole [ __ ] Street so nobody can pass
is you guys sit there shooting the [ __ ]
there's two types of people that ride
bicycles there's the people that just
wear regular clothes and I find them to
be courteous and then there's people who
dress like they're in the Tour de France
and actually it's a [ __ ] bike race
and they're the biggest [ __ ] on the
planet and they they blow through stop
signs like that was what I did yesterday
I made sure that I stopped at every
[ __ ] stop sign now buy stop is I mean
I wrote as slowly as humanly possible
before I could then continue is that
sort of a rolling stop you know what I
mean but I did stop I didn't just do
that thing where you stand up on your
pedals and you look left and right and
blow through a [ __ ] red light and
then you get hit and then they frost
your bicycle like something tragic
happened not saying every person that
died on a bicycle was not hit tragically
because somebody was texting not saying
that either but I realized I'm too old
to ride a bicycle that's like a 10 or 12
speed design with those handles because
the way you you the way your position
and then you have to have your head up
[ __ ] it hurts my neck so I need to go
more of like the the beach rambler beach
[ __ ] what do you call this thing's
mountain bike thing you know mountain
bike style while not being on a mountain
whatever you call that I think you call
that white guy over 50 bicycle cycling
is that what it's called is that what
people talk about my shoulder rehab
people if you're rehabbing a rotator
cuff I finally learned that you have to
go excruciatingly ly slow even though
that information was conveyed to me
immediately it's taken me all these
years and I am up to I'm using the pink
white one powder I did two sets of ten
and the last one I did eleven and I
didn't have to ice it no
anti-inflammatory nothing it's felt
great the last two days so tomorrow is
is another rehab day every three days I
do it I do these exercises and I'm this
time I'm going to try to go
three sets of eleven you know the old me
Beale hey let's go up to [ __ ] twelve
or thirteen four three sets and that's
just enough to twin just the [ __ ]
thing so if I can just get this [ __ ]
thing up once I get up I know I keep
saying this but I'm saying it for me so
I can get past this [ __ ] once you get up
to like four or five pounds doing the
exercises that I'm doing then you can
increase weight without having to worry
but that going for one pound to two
pounds I told you my deal I'm gonna get
all the way up to three sets of twenty
so 60 reps 60 pounds and then when I
switched to a 2 pounder I'm gonna do the
1 pounder two sets of maybe 15 each and
then the third set is gonna be with the
2 pounder and I'm only gonna do three
reps and see how that feels and then
I'll gradually increase it up to where I
can do one full set with the 2 pounder
and the first two sets are still gonna
be with the 1 pound and plus the warm-up
and just gradually increase that and
just gauge it on how and you know how
much my shoulders talking to me to move
forward back off or stay where I'm at
and I don't know why I didn't do that
before but probably cuz I was traveling
and all of that [ __ ] but I talked to my
agent yesterday about possibly setting
up some shows there's a particular venue
out here that is uh you know struggling
or whatever so is thinking of doing like
a little run of shows there you know and
let you know just well you know I won't
charge him anything you know people pay
some money for the tickets they buy some
alcohol have a good [ __ ] time that
guy makes this money I don't need to do
[ __ ] all I need to do is just go up
there it shake the rust off and all of
that type of stuff I think it could be I
think it'd be a good thing for everybody
so hopefully I can put that together
sooner rather than later sorry got the
hiccups alright let's talk about some
[ __ ] here that happened in my life so I
went out to my little podcast studio /
drum studio slash garage and I
in the side door okay I have a nice
little carpet down and all of that [ __ ]
right now come walking in and there's a
little gecko somehow it's got in through
the side door which I don't know they
can really [ __ ] flatten out their
bodies I don't know what their deal is
so my Jesus Christ so I go to like you
know give it a little flip you know up
and over the threshold to get it out of
there but I didn't want to hurt him but
I also needed to get him out of there so
I sort of no pun intended with the
reptile reference here I sort of
alligator armed it with my foot and I
missed him and God bless him he [ __ ]
D took off and he was on a hardwood
floor before he got to the carpet and
that was my last window to try and get
this [ __ ] and then once he got to the
carpet he went underneath my suitcase
and by the time I zoomed the wheels you
know pushed it all out of the way he was
underneath the couch and the couch sits
real low like a [ __ ] lowrider right
sort of couch no not high legs or
anything so I put the flashlight my
phone and now I have a phone again and I
saw the little [ __ ] underneath there
right so I had this old rolling stone
one the one that Adam Yauch was on the
cover when he died right and uh I'm
trying to [ __ ] push him out and I
just couldn't get him then I just
decided like you know what there's
nothing to eat in here there's nothing
to [ __ ] in here this thing's eventually
gonna leave on its own power I just said
[ __ ] it now the old me I also didn't
want to pick up the sofa and [ __ ] up my
shoulder so I was just like you know
what [ __ ] you want to stay in here
and [ __ ] be a lizard I don't give a
[ __ ] so I now share my studio with this
little [ __ ] lizard right I had a real
weird weekend you know my wife's going
through it like we're literally down to
single digits here as far as when the
babies come in as far as days left and
so I wanted to make her something sweet
right so I was out at the grocery store
and I knew I was gonna make her a cake
or some cupcakes for her birthday
so I got some of that that dark
chocolate that [ __ ] that cooking
chocolate or whatever and they had this
recipe for these peanut butter
cheesecake brownies so how do I make
those [ __ ] things
this weekend right so go downstairs she
doesn't know I'm doing it I'm [ __ ]
making this [ __ ] and for whatever reason
they said to put like you know tin foil
in the the casserole dish type of thing
and spray him so then he can like the
tin foil you lift it up and out when
you're done and the whole thing comes
out it's actually kind of slick I guess
right so anyway I but I didn't have good
tin foil was that cheap [ __ ] you know
yeah there's like Reynolds Wrap and then
there's these other [ __ ] where if you
would like to like the the littlest
amount of pressure you accidentally tear
the [ __ ] thing in half so why do I
make these [ __ ] things that I'm
tasting along the way I'm like ah man
that's gonna taste delicious right and I
and I cooked these [ __ ] things I
don't know what happen I cut out of
square and I ate it immediately it was
the worst [ __ ] tasting thing I'd ever
tasted in my life you know it reminded
me of a long time ago I had season
tickets to the Pats in 1989 right I
always tell you that but I did right and
we were all shit-faced and we thought we
had the grill going so we put our food
on it our burgers and stuff and then the
fire went out we had to get it going
again we were so hammered we were
shooting lighter fluid under the
charcoals but it was also getting onto
the burgers and when I ate the burger it
was just like I could taste the lighter
fluid in it but I was so [ __ ]
hammered and hungry I ate it anyways and
like the [ __ ] hangover I got was
brutal so I was eating this this peanut
butter cheesecake brownie and I was
having a flashback to that like why does
it taste like there's like chemicals in
it this [ __ ] terrible and I was done
eating it you know I came upstairs I
told my wife I said I blew it man they
don't eat him that terrible would throw
him out tomorrow morning and the next
day I went downstairs and I went to
throw him out and I looked at the space
where the brownie was and there was a
little triangle piece of [ __ ]
aluminum foil gone I think I ate the
aluminum foil that was that that was the
taste because I then a in the center
where it didn't stick and they were
[ __ ] delicious so
I don't know what the point of that
story was just be careful people if
you're out there bacon during this
[ __ ] pandemic if you have the cheap
[ __ ] aluminum foil which was all that
was left where I went just watch out cuz
that that stuff you eat aluminum foil it
stays with you for a few days oh by the
way here's something that I'm going to
attempt and I want to thank all you guys
who listen to my podcast over the years
because I'm gonna [ __ ] with electricity
in my house there's just a couple of
outlets you know about three or four
where one of the outlets works and the
other one if you go to stick it in like
it's like a baby when it doesn't like
what you're given and just sort of just
lets it dribble back down its chin
it doesn't like what's eating you know
that's what it just sort of spits the
plug out so I need some new outlets and
I watched this YouTube video of a guy
replace him it looks really easy I'm
just terrified of electricity but
fortunately our fuse box everything is
labeled correctly and I know all you do
is just you just plug a lamp into the
outlet you turn it on it's good and then
you throw the switch and you've become
the [ __ ] things off it doesn't work
you know you're good so I'm gonna be
attempting that and I'm just gonna do
one if I get that then I'll be good
and I watched a bunch of videos and I'm
aware - now when you go to put the wire
back in if it's the one where you got to
wrap it around make sure there's no
insulation in there and then also make
sure that you don't take away too much
insulation where there's bare wire
beyond where it would wrap around you
want the insulation to be go right up to
where the nut is what that you wrap it
around and screw it back in so I
understand all of that [ __ ] and I'm
gonna give it a shot [ __ ] it Oh Billy
fix it
alright he likes everybody some
advertising here he likes hellix oh this
is where they wrote this copy for me I'm
pretty one-of-a-kind right I'm unique
I'm special well helix sleep makes
mattresses made for unique for how
unique we all are and how we all sleep
differently not being able to sleep
because of today's politics you love
life any other drama you talk about in
your show oh I guess I was supposed to
talk about that
sleeping on how about the fact I'm
having a kid any friggin day and I'm
gonna be 52 years old you know and I'm
wondering if I'm gonna you know stay
alive here long enough sleeping on a
terrible mattress in before HELOCs slash
on the road what is this like just
suggestions for me to improve your
content putting people to sleep any
other funny stereotype slash antidotes
slash thoughts that fit your content oh
this is like direction can I start this
over again let's go back to one okay
I've done a couple of movies here we go
helix hellicksen
you know people up pretty one-of-a-kind
right I'm unique well hellix sleep makes
mattresses made for how unique we all
are and how we all sleep differently you
know I haven't been able to sleep
because of my rotator Cup boy oh boy I
would love a mattress helix sleep makes
personalized mattresses made right here
in America yeah and ships straight to
your door with free no contact delivery
free returns gross and a hundred nights
sleep trial go rouse to choose a
mattress helix made a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you if you like
a mattress that that's really soft or
firm you sleep on your side or your back
or your stomach or you sleep really hot
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every unique taste
I love helix but you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by GQ magazine Wired magazine and
Apartment Therapy just go to helix sleep
calm slash bird take that two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up
give you a full refund if you don't love
it but you will you know what that
reminds me of I was out my wife was
watching my 600-pound life last night
there was this big fat guy who weighed
over 600 pounds and the doctor comes
that he says hey buddy if you don't drop
some weight we can't do the [ __ ]
bypass stomach [ __ ] shrinkage thing
to you and he's like ok but I need my
pain meds so I'm in a lot of pain to
guys like I'm not giving you any pain
you're in pain cuz you're overweight all
right lay off the pizzas so what does
this guy do
he [ __ ] eats a bunch of pizzas he
gains [ __ ] 80 pounds which is putting
on like 5 pounds at that that weight he
gains eighty [ __ ] pounds and also
pulls out all of his [ __ ] hair on the
top of his head one strand at a time so
the guy comes back to check out him he's
now six hundred eighty-five pounds and
he looks like [ __ ] Ben Franklin at 28
you know you know cuz he stood at
black-haired had great [ __ ] head of
hair it killed me watching him pull all
that out you know and he was just really
a manipulated guy manipulating type of a
personality and I was really having a
reaction to it you know Nia was trying
to watch I was like they should just let
this guy die I mean what the what what
is he doing you know [ __ ] what do you
keep it up around for I you know I swear
to God
you know I might this might be a little
Trump but if I was running I would just
put that guy in a giant hammock and I
just take him out to sea and then that's
it you just leave him there and you let
all the [ __ ] killer whales that's so
[ __ ] mean I'm sorry I mean he was no
he was like human sushi anyway let's get
back to the advertising here him does
everybody what a common issue men failed
walk it what what's a common issue men's
face but don't always want to talk about
think long and hard do you yeah 40% have
been by age 40 struggle with not being
able to get and maintain an erection
look at me I'm doing alright then huh
why do guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing when they can turn instead to
medicine in science expensive pills
injection where no man wants an
injection share any experiences you've
had with doctors in dealing with edie
issues is somebody actually going to do
that hims connects you with real
licensed doctors and fda-approved
pharmaceutical products to treat edie
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
combat
edie prescription solutions backed by
science and made affordable answer
questions about your medical history and
chat with the doctor for a confidential
review if approved by doctor products
are shipped directly to your door this
is going to be the hardest year of your
life you know what's funny is the fact
that if you do have this problem that
you really can't talk about it nobody
said they're going like if I had this
problem why the [ __ ] would I want to
deal why would I want to talk about it
you know this is a stereotype guys
should be able to talk about this stuff
but until you can't hymns you can talk
about it confidentially well-known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you combat your
IDI prescription solutions backed by
science and made more affordable answer
questions about your medical history and
chat with the doctor for confidential
review if approved by the doctor
products are shipped directly to your
door this is going to be the hardest
year of your life sorry I already read
that try hymns today by starting out
with a free online visit go to four hems
comm slash burr Edie that's fo r hims
com /b you are our capital Edie for hems
comm slash buried e prescription
products are subject to doctor approval
and require online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see the
website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you went in person to the doctor's
office or pharmacy remember that's for
hims com slash BER II D all right should
we get into some of the reads here for
the week
this is one that I just found today it
says hi bill [ __ ] you so right there I'm
in I've got something that may interest
you you Jin you ginger [ __ ] I'm a
British I'm British and a big football
fan not soccer [ __ ] you it's called
football and that's already two reasons
to hate me I'm a I say I'm a big
football fan in fact I'm also a fat [ __ ]
that's three reasons anyway I have an
interesting baseball story that you
might not know if you do then [ __ ] you
in fact I'm too locked down drunk to be
able to give the details in coherent
enough fashion for your fat ginger your
fat finger reading skills to manage just
look up Gary Thomasson the ex dodger and
Yankee player who went to Japan his name
has become a byword for something
pointless but beautifully maintained
look it up it's [ __ ] interesting I'm
going to bed now Cheers
fat [ __ ] so and so PS I love your show
all right so I looked this up where the
hell is it
the unfortunate legacy of Gary Thomasson
and he was right he was a guy that
played in the MLB played for the Dodgers
and the Yankees and then he signed a big
contract in Japan here is his story Gary
Thomasson was an American baseball
player who lost his mojo when he moved
to Japan but to spices
despite his less than stellar career his
name still lives on today thanks to
Japanese artists I hope I said I'm not
gonna say this place because I guess
Ogawa Gen pi it's a killer name whatever
I guess negawatt gen Pi Thomason has
become and he poem I don't want to say
that word Jesus Christ I need to get
smarter but maybe [ __ ] talking to
people
eople em I spelt it wrong
let's see pronunciation how do you uh
[ __ ] you with the [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] windows have I ever said yes to
any of that when are you gonna quit
pronunciation how do you say it how do
you always I had to sound off alright
here we go let's try it again
let's try it again eponym eponym I never
would have guessed that alright his name
has become an eponym for a truly bizarre
type of architecture what the [ __ ] just
happened
it just scrolled without me his name has
become an epidemic
for a truly bizarre type of architecture
objects that are completely useless but
still carefully maintained if you've
ever lived in a major city you've
probably seen your fair share of
architectural oddities perhaps you've
spotted a handrail where there aren't
any stairs or a door that opens to a
brick wall
maybe you've noticed vents with nothing
to ventilate or a section of a fence you
can easily walk around pictured pictured
above you can see a Skyway that no
longer connects to anything yet wasn't
demolished and it with it's connected
building for some reason well that's
probably because they would have charged
more money I would think to take that
[ __ ] thing down the other buildings
like poor 9 we're not paying for and
they were like well [ __ ] it then we're
just gonna leave it I'm guessing I have
no idea all right the whole bushel here
here we go if you've ever lived in a
major city I read all of that Papa Papa
anyway there are these are some remnants
of expanding cities why did cuz it keeps
loading advertising it keeps moving on
me here these are remnants of expanding
cities but what's confusing is many of
these ridiculous doors and pointless
pipes are still carefully maintained
while they serve no purpose they're
repainted when they grow rusty or
repaired when they fall apart they also
have their own name there called
Thomason's so who nicknamed these silly
structures and why well the culprit is a
Japanese artist named gusano ah Jen PI
one day in 1972 he was on his lunch
break in Tokyo when something caught his
eye that's on my bucket list to go there
by the way
it was a staircase that went up and down
like all staircases do only there was no
door at the top they were stairs to
nowhere but what really amazed agus
Ogawa Agassi guwa was the railing
it was obviously it was obvious that one
time or another the railing had come
apart but what blue I guess Agha was
mine was someone had fixed the darn
thing
now the railing was good as new even
though there was no reason why anyone
would ever use those stairs mystified I
guess I was searched the city for more
worthless wonders whenever he found an
out-of-place pole or a gate in the
middle of nowhere he'd snap a photo he
considered these doors and stairs
artistic byproducts of the city I'm
gonna give you this guy's name so you
can look it up his work it's a K I'll
spell it
aka aka se G AWA I can't imagine there's
somebody else maybe that name is like
Mike over there so I'll give you his
last [ __ ] name here Jen PI g en Pei
if you want to look up his work as I
continue to read here one day 1972 let's
see Bob uh it was obvious that at one
time or another I'd read that oh so he
considered them artistic byproducts of
the city and soon he was published
publishing the pictures and put in a
photography magazine complete with
little articles on the name the nature
of their existence that's a great book
coffee table book he also created a name
for these vest Vista geo structures I
don't know how to say that word [ __ ]
getting killed here today okay let's
look this one up vested Geel
pronunciation here we go here we go
vestigial oh man you got to work that
into your [ __ ] well you can't really
go to a party I got I can't you forgot
how to say it
vestigial I like that one getting sick
Toyota's vestigial [ __ ] so in order to
that make sense so in order to be a
Thomason an object must be cared for
even though it's completely pointless
wait I've skipped over a bunch of [ __ ]
god dammit he called him Thomas since
after baseball player Gary Thomasson who
was played for two played for teams like
the Dodgers and the Yankees while
Thomason was a fine player in the States
things changed dramatically when he
signed on with the Yomiuri Giants a team
based in Tokyo once Thomason arrived in
the Land of the Rising Sun he couldn't
hit a ball to save his life I bet what
happened was he got in his head and then
he compiled it with the fact that he was
this American representing an entire
country and the pressure just got too
big where are we here but I couldn't hit
a ball to save its life people called
him the giant human fan because all he
was doing because that's was all he was
doing with the bat was stirring up air
you see that baseball of sports fans are
sports fans around the world after
Thomason set the all-time Japanese
strikeout record in 1981 the coaches
benched the poor guy and that's how
Thomason served out the rest of his
contract sitting in the dugout and
making money for doing nothing
according to Agra saga Sagwa akka Segawa
who's who's a huge baseball fan Thomason
had a fully-formed body yet served no
purpose to the world oh my god but just
like those fences and banisters he found
around Tokyo the man was still being
maintained Wow
so in order to be a Thomason an object
must be cared for even though it's
completely pointless the concept caught
on and soon people were submitting their
own Thomason Thomasson's to August Sega
was for approval I guess a go vote for
approval 1985 the artist published his
findings in a book called hyper art
Thomason which was translated into
English in 2009 oh my god
this is like international bill buckner
the
book inspired a new group of Thomas and
hunters particular in particular Lee in
San Francisco in August Sega was
publishers even started a website where
they could submit their artistic
discoveries
unfortunately Gary Thomasson's family
isn't exactly pleased with the way the
ballplayer is being portrayed after all
who wants to be remembered for being
useless of course as a radio host Roman
Mars points out how many other
ballplayers from the 70s and 80s can you
remember thanks to I guess a go a bunch
a bunch I can name behalf of the [ __ ]
Big Red Machine I can name all the
Yankees and the Red Sox you don't
believe me here we go
alright Dave concepción George Foster
Pete Rose Tom SEMA Johnny Bench
Sparky Lyle Tony Pena with Cesar
Geronimo on that neigh what a [ __ ] it
was he on that team Jose Cruz jr.
Richards does some Astros for you the
[ __ ] Dodgers Ron Cey Bill Russell
Davey Lopes Steve Garvey Steve Yaga
Dusty Baker Tommy Lasorda don't [ __ ]
challenge I can never have his Greg or
Craig Nettles
Bucky Dent Chris Chambliss who the [ __ ]
was their second basement Bucky Dent was
short right
Thurman Munson rest his soul Reggie
Jackson Lou Piniella Ron Guidry
Louisiana Lightning Jim Rice Fred Lynn
Carl Yastrzemski mitts [ __ ] you talking
about it's a dumb point
thanks to August Sega was Gary
Thompson's name will live on wherever
people find door knobs attached to brick
walls or roads that lead smack dab into
dead ends well now I got to look that
I'll look it up after the podcast so
there you go Thank You Leland you get a
drunk [ __ ] British guy guy just ate
up 15 minutes of the podcast god bless
you all right Milwaukee hi Bill I'm a
lady listener
welcome welcome I love when the ladies
right in I'm a lady listener from
Milwaukee Wisconsin I was wondering what
your take is on the Democratic National
Convention which is supposed to be in
Milwaukee in August do you think it will
still happen what do you think needs to
happen at the convention to get people
excited about Biden Jesus cry I mean Joe
Biden making you exciting is excited
it'd be like having somebody tone-deaf
sing a [ __ ] song on you know in the
right key it's just not gonna happen I
hope you have a chance to visit in the
summertime so do I it is beautiful here
right now I love Milwaukee and you know
I don't know I'm at this point I'm
rooting can you root for other
Republicans to canal Republican [ __ ]
take the spot we can just start over
again I don't know I don't know is just
a weird weird ass [ __ ] transitional
time here in politics all right doctors
salaries by the way somebody recently I
did a reddit asked me anything and
people ask me about overrated and
underrated cities and I said over eight
it was a lot of the major cities because
a lot of had to do because I had been to
him so many times but just the traffic
congestion and all of that [ __ ] how much
they cost you know the money he got to
spend it all on that [ __ ] no place to
park and I was naming my like top three
underrated Milwaukee Wisconsin
Chattanooga Tennessee Knoxville also
honorable mention big fan of Tennessee
and Tulsa Oklahoma are some of the ones
that I went to that have [ __ ] amazing
overrated are and these are all great
cities they just too many people move to
him Austin Texas too many [ __ ] people
I mean it is just an absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ] show trying to get from the airport
to get trying to get to the airport into
Austin to your hotel is it's like if
you've ever landed in Washington Dulles
Airport and then you know
Shifa coming from the west coast you
land right at rush hour I mean it's like
[ __ ] two hours just to get to your
[ __ ] hotel that's why I always try to
fly into Reagan fly right in there jump
in a cab boom you're there it costs more
but I don't give a [ __ ] I'm kind of into
the the same way I'm into smaller cities
I'm into smaller airports I like doing
that and I don't give a [ __ ] if I have
to pay more money I just like that way
better than dealing with the bigger the
bigger ones I liked going to when I was
a younger man but now that I'm an older
man and I don't want to [ __ ] deal
with lugging my luggage and all of that
[ __ ] and then they have wheels my
luggage has wheels like everybody else
all right and I'm still talking about
lugging it that's how [ __ ] old I am
all right doctors salaries everybody
dear bodacious Billington billing team
okay come watch it when daughter has a
virtual virtual dance recital hang on a
second I got it I'll be right back
what's up what are you gonna go do all
right hang on I'm coming up coming up
coming all right I'll hang on a second
guys all right I just crushed the
parent/daughter dance killed it you know
some moves that have never been seen
before hold all right I'm back all right
doctors salaries dear bodacious billing
team that intro was what Gmail's
suggested to me when I typed bill that's
artificial intelligence for you I love
the podcast okay some orthopedic
surgeons and plastic surgeons make over
$750,000 a year while many general
medicine doctors and pediatricians make
under 225 thousand dollars a year the
highest-paid surgeons are clearly
overpaid at what as compared to the
other ones dude somebody's operating on
your face I mean how do you how do you
put a price on that
you gotta I don't think I would want to
bargain bin shop and for that I don't
know
but do you think general medicine
doctors like your primary care doctor or
your daughter's pediatrician and their
pair's peers are underpaid well this
next point is what I was gonna bring up
they often leave medical school with two
hundred thousand three and thousand
dollars in debt physicians often works
60 plus hours a week with 10 to 20 of
those hours being spent doing paperwork
in dealing with [ __ ] pharmaceutical
and insurance companies we need more
doctors and with those salaries versus
debts we won't get them do you think we
should pay doctors not surgeons more or
do you think that even with that debt
they should be happy with what they have
oh I imagine like with any business the
people that employed them are keeping
the lion's share of the money and they
probably exploit people like it's kind
of I mean capitalism gets a bad rap I
mean I just kind of see people getting
exploited in every country that I
[ __ ] go to so it I think it's a human
thing not really a form of government
thing but yeah I mean III think out of
everybody out there as far as like
earning a living earning the money that
you're you're being paid the fact that
these people help you prevent you from
dying I don't know that how you put a
price on that that's really the most
important thing out there is staying
alive and as far as like orthopedic
surgeons I mean yeah your quality of
life is so much more improved those are
the people that give you like you know
hip replacements knee replacement you
can actually walk around right [ __ ] I
gotta look that up or if the P I get all
of those confuse except for gynecology
just because there's been so many jokes
about it
I know podiatrists too that's just
because I'm old or the Pedic surgeon
spelt it wrong
[Music]
orthopedic surgeon for fucksakes no they
just give me a bunch of [ __ ]
orthopedic surgeons names
all right Wikipedia is a branch of
surgery concerned with involving the
musculoskeletal system by the way let me
see who's the first guy that comes up oh
it's people in your neighborhood I was
like who's like the [ __ ] Kevin Hart
you know like the biggest or Sebastian
like the biggest the Dave Chappelle of
orthopedic surgeons that if you google
them like their name just comes up
that's [ __ ] interesting we need more
doctors in this okay all right yeah I
mean I don't have a problem giving them
more money I mean I don't pay him I I
imagine there's somebody that the guy
who owns the hospital the team owner
that's actually kind of fascinating then
as far as like Plastic Surgeons you know
everybody thinks it's somebody getting
tits or [ __ ] fake asses or something
like that but you know there's also
people that you know get into car
accidents and stuff like that and these
people you know get you know lacerations
to the face you did such a great job
buddy yes you did you have fun in the
dance class yeah how did did daddy dance
okay yeah I'm making a very thin what
you do when you interview a kid you
don't ask yes or no questions you gotta
ask how did you feel about dance class
what is it that you like about dance
class I like about mommy go poopy you
like it that Mommy goes poopy she's
she's potty-trained now so she's all
about poop yeah okay that's your
statement on dance classes that Mommy
goes poopy okay is there anything else
you would like to add because I got to
get back to the podcast I like a play
keris play Candyland chutes and ladders
what about those walkie-talkies
walkie-talkies all right are we gonna
play when I'm done here
come on buddy we're gonna go play
wiffleball okay t-ball yeah t-ball sorry
sorry well I I'm old so I used the
different references and then we play
catch yeah
all right come on let me let me knock
this out and then we'll go play all
right hey great job buddy
you got it all right thank you mom all
right where was I okay advice email
popping boners at work or here's a guy
doesn't need for hims I'm a 21 year old
male from I'm not gonna say where who
moved to Washington for a decent
education
all right the state he's from is also
the last name of one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and that state
isn't known for its education and my
family wanted me to have a chance in
today's world
anyway I recently got a job at a grocery
store so I can make some cash on the
side and take advantage of an increased
need of healthy people willing to work
during a pandemic here's the problem 99%
of the women in this state dress like
they just ran the Boston Marathon they
wear yoga pants that show off their hips
or loose shirts that show a lot of
cleavage maybe I'm just an ignorant male
but in the state of blah blah blah most
people most people women included wear
pants or cargo shorts that aren't
flaunting their bodies 24/7 I'm having a
difficult time not having hard-ons
during my shift hours I'm not claiming
to have a Magnum dong but when I look
down you can clearly see I'm aroused
since I tucked my shirt in and wear a
belt like a gentleman
[Laughter]
if me is there I'm sure we'll end up
being my fault
oh [ __ ] shots fired but I swear I'm not
drooling over these women it's just hard
punting included intended I think you
meant to not notice they're mostly
beautiful bodies especially when they
flaunt it so casually it's kind of like
if lady has really colorful hair or in
an aura of an attractive 30-plus year
old lady wears white yoga pants with a
black thong it's something your eyes
brain and dong would want to look at any
advice would be appreciated go [ __ ]
yourself my advice is hang in there
buddy hang in there all right you got to
positive going for yourself one your
dick works there's people out there they
got to take four hymns you're all right
okay so you're fine and then secondly
you know I imagine if you got a job at a
titty bar the first couple of days you'd
be like god damn look at all these
[ __ ] titties and then after a while
it's just titties I think you'll get
used to it and I think you'll be fine
as long as you don't start rubbing your
dick you know with your hand or up
against whatever [ __ ] don't they have
food or some [ __ ] you should be fine
you know but yeah what are you supposed
to do if they're coming in they're
wearing their [ __ ] I mean listen I've
been out here in LA forever and I still
almost hit a tree every time I Drive
down the street some of the the lack of
clothing that the women wear out here
god bless them I'm not complaining all
right hey Piper
really listen I watched enough [ __ ]
baseball to know when the catcher's
frame and the [ __ ] strike zone to
make a ball look like a strike so get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
hypothetical dilemma bill I got one for
you
you're you but you're not famous for
comedy okay oh is it DeLuca you're you
but you're not famous for comedy you're
just a hardware store employee in Boston
a member of British royalty falls in
love with you it doesn't even matter if
you love her back maybe you do the
question is could you keep your mouth
shut
and eat your cake and have it too Oh
would I marry her no I couldn't do it
could you marry into that and be
responsible for acting as the palace
required no I would feel like a [ __ ]
loser
remember you might get all sorts of cool
luxuries but have to attend lots of
events though keep in mind that life in
a one-bedroom in Medford might not be
that bad no I could I couldn't do that
if I loved her I would do it but even
then I would just be I would be Khonsu
saying hey you don't need to buy me
anything can I at least pay for the
cable and the palace can I do something
can I wash the Royal dishes I have to do
something to earn my keep
I'm not gonna sit here because if I
don't really honestly don't have to do
anything other than go to these two I'll
tell you what I would do is I would
become a [ __ ] drunk I would become a
[ __ ] drunk oh wait a minute
wait a minute I just got a [ __ ]
message from my [ __ ] agent
today I was fond of a purposeful oh no
Jesus Christ I was hoping that's about
moving a [ __ ] date god dammit
you know you start to get excited
alright let's let's let's wrap up the
podcast yeah all right great songs not
the hits this will go in deep cuts I
don't know why we haven't done this
before I love this [ __ ] all right this
guy says so this lady says wait did I
answer this thing yeah I I couldn't I
couldn't do that I would have to keep
working in the [ __ ] hardware so but
then you have a level of fame and then
you have security around you it would it
would I wouldn't want to be famous for
being with somebody who's famous that's
not how I'm [ __ ] wired and I gotta
tell you from what I heard Medford's
really [ __ ] nice now you know great
songs not the hits plus you know then
I'd have to move to England and I
wouldn't get to watch all my [ __ ]
teams I couldn't go to games that's the
one thing that I'd only thing that sucks
about being in this [ __ ] business is
I really wish that you know I could live
in Massachusetts again you know and just
go to a [ __ ] Red Sox game Bruins
Celtics Patriots I really wish I could
do that that's [ __ ] hilarious if I
ended up doing that and I missed the
entire championship [ __ ] two decades
I was away although it was fun to be
behind enemy lines while all of that was
happening to anyway all right here we go
deep cuts here great songs not the hits
so if you guys haven't heard this
premise this is basically like you know
anybody who listens to ac/dc on the
radio they know you shook me all night
long they might not know what's next to
the moon get it hot so this is people
letting you know about the deeper cuts
stuff like that all right great songs
not the hits now I love everything by
Steely Dan but I feel the track doesn't
get nearly enough credit for the song is
don't take me alive which is much more
rock than their traditional sound
my wife's a big Steely Dan fan I don't
know their songs by name I did see them
in concert and they were [ __ ] great
the cult most people either know them
for firewoman from 1989 sonic temple or
she sells sanctuary from 1985's
Love however 1987's electric album
produced by Rick Rubin has some killer
tracks including electric ocean bad fun
and love removal machine keep up the
great work now I got a look now am I
crazy was was Matt Sorum the drummer in
that band let me see here I got to look
this up doggone it I gotta get to the
bottom of this now why won't this
[ __ ] thing open up where did it go
where the [ __ ] is it oh it's all the way
down here alright the cult the cult Matt
Sorum he's best known as a member of the
rock band Guns N'Roses with whom he
recorded three studio and he remembers
supergroup Velvet Revolver [ __ ] love
that band I saw them at the the Wiltern
Sorum is currently a member of the
touring project kings chaos and it's
firmly remember the cult let's see let's
see let's see when he's 59 he looks
[ __ ] great
62 89 when was he in the cult years
active come on I wish they would do this
you know they do that with teams like
you played for the pages from this to
this I'll have to look at this later cuz
I'm gettin bumping up against here on
time I will show you something that's
[ __ ] amazing is underrated I'll give
you an underrated overrated underrated
as far as New England Patriot coaches
Chuck Fairbanks look at this [ __ ]
Patriots number one draft picks you
should see this guy's draft that he had
in 73
you know if Chuck Noll didn't do it he
did I would say that Chuck Fairbanks
Patriots number one draft picks
there we go oh [ __ ] you
well I'd it's not gonna come up for me
of course because I'm doing the podcast
I'll read these to you at some point but
one one year that day it was like John
Hannah Sam Cunningham Darryl Stingley
and then the next year we had like Mike
Haynes Stanley Morgan Raymond Claiborne
there's incredible incredible teams that
by the way that 76 team was one roughing
the passer [ __ ] call away from going
to the [ __ ] Super Bowl they got beat
on that call but that was a great team
that 76 Raiders team was a great [ __ ]
team but we went we went toe to toe with
them and we're actually gonna win the
[ __ ] game in their goddamn their own
[ __ ] stadium well they actually
shared it with the ACE whatever their
[ __ ] two-bedroom apartment that they
had with the Oakland A's and we were
actually gonna win that [ __ ] game and
then it was a very highly highly highly
questionable [ __ ] roughing the passer
call you know and for all Al Davis
bitching that the NFL was against them
uh there's no [ __ ] way he bitched
after that call at least for a week all
right Billy Joel river of dreams you've
heard the track the title track on the
album the sleeper songs are Great Wall
of China a song about his old manager
[ __ ] him oh that's right cuz he got
[ __ ] out of money right and I thought
was his brother-in-law and famous last
words the last song in the album in a
last song with lyrics he has released
okay that's another bucket list think -
I got to see him in concert he always
plays [ __ ] Madison Square Garden and
I'm out here I got to see that guy in
concert I saw him one time you ever see
him on Howard Stern it's like [ __ ] 8
o'clock in the morning he's absolutely
crushing it just hearing him just play
piano how good he is [ __ ] amazing
alright 2 Live Crew has some great
tracks yeah I know we have all heard the
classics we want some [ __ ] you know
I've never really listened to them but
don't underestimate throw the D the
intricate drumbeat combined with the Mel
allows for some smooth lyrics to relax
your brain I really enjoy listening to
this track before I go to bed
throw the D I got a listen to this I'll
tell you underrated drum track is Run
DMC my adidas if you want to play along
to something that's [ __ ] amazing to
play if you play drums throw the D yeah
you know what came up throat throw the
damn cow 2 Live Crew alright let's
listen to this thing for a second
I might download this immediately just
the title alone is hilarious oh Jesus an
ultra sonic toothbrush everybody just in
case Oh what exactly what I don't need
wait a minute
what is this thing oh this is for you
start seeing patients ruined that sheath
with an ordinary brush and decided to
partner with the product engineer to
create dr. masse Spiker and mark roller
this music is so compelling
did you believe it's about a toothbrush
that here we go okay I'll have to give
that of a better listen but I have to
tell you I enjoyed the music and the
toothbrush thing a little better I know
it's a classic I know it's a classic so
I will go back and listen to it uh the
cult of Rick Rubin I got a listen to
that [ __ ] thing okay that's it
everybody that's the podcast everyone
that's it
don't riot don't [ __ ] go after
mom-and-pop stores please don't do that
[ __ ] please keep it focused on what it
should be about okay can we can we try
to do that for once George Floyd let's
keep his name out there and all of that
stuff and everybody just sit down and
[ __ ] work it out and the world
becomes a better place you know
let's go positive here no one's
listening you're [ __ ] your goddamn
like inflammatory [ __ ] let's let's bring
people together can we do that can we do
that that's it all right I'm predicting
it right now the Denver the [ __ ]
presidential election I'm calling it
right now the diverse the dope on
pay-per-view
who knows maybe maybe maybe
what's-his-face maybe maybe maybe what's
his name Joe Biden who knows maybe he
has some sort of [ __ ] left hook in
him that's just gonna catch the current
champ on the jaw who knows who knows I
don't know I've always found all of
those those presidential debates to just
be just unwashable just politicians just
have this unique like outside their own
body sort of vibe and I just think it's
it's because of the pressure that
they're underneath you know what I mean
like that guy went to Japan and couldn't
hit anymore I don't know I don't think I
want to watch it now why am I still
talking all right I have [ __ ] to do all
right god bless all you go [ __ ] yourself
I'll check in on you on Thursday